Hello there.
Oh, it's hot.
It is warm, yeah.
Now,
we did this in Alabama
with tiny, little pots of paint
at very high frame rates.
Now we're gonna
step up the size.
We've got bigger bangers.
You've got some there?
Yeah
Yeah, these are about
five times the size
So, on that one,
I was sort like, stood there,
didn't really care that much.
Do you still have your
paint splats from Alabama?
Oh yeah.
Still has Alabama splats.
I'll tell you what though,
I am not standing anywhere near these.
There are some of these
videos where it's like,
yeah, whatever, boo.
I'm scared of this one,
I'm actually worried.
I think the glass is going
to go flying everywhere.
This is not a good idea,
so don't do it.
You might want to protect
your eyes as well,
some paint may hit the lens.
All right.
Try and get them
as close together as possible,
K?
And then,
don't pussy out.
Literally,
you got time, okay?
Yeah
Plunge it in properly,
and then run.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
So start here,
three, two, one, light.
What happened?
One of them I couldn't light.
I'm bleeding out my finger now
Oh yeah. Let's get a
close up of the blood.
Lovely.
That is urinating blood.
It's going pretty deep.
I think there's glass still in there.
Alright. Judging by the blood.
Message to the audience?
Don't do that at home.
Oh yeah.
I was really close to it.
Is that the most severe
injury we've had so far?
I got burned before,
but that was probably
the most out of control.
Didn't know what was
going to happen one.
Yeah.
That's the scariest one we've ever done.
Do you have any scissors?
Yeah.
It feels really weak.
It's bleeding through the
plaster and the thick bandages.
I wonder if there's glass
really still in there.
Still really hurts though.
Let's look at your actual blood.
It looks like all the other
stains on your lab coat,
but it's actually your
real human blood there.
Alright,
what are we doing now?
I'm going to mix
two colors of paint
in each pot
and then get two bangers
on a stick.
Each one.
Dip them as deep
into the pot as I can.
And just sort of take it.
You're going to sit in between them?
Yeah
Do you reckon you'll flinch?
Probably.
All right. This one is
called the lab coat ruiner.
Aw, man
it's right on the lens.
God's sake.
There's as a splotch
directly in the middle.
It's all over my face.
I can't wipe it anywhere.
Where can I wipe it?
Hang on.
That ring just hanging in the tree there.
Remains.
You look good.
Let's have a run through
of what we've achieved in
Banger week.
Well, the damage this week, to me,
to start with
is, uh, my fingers been
basically blown off.
It really hurts
Legos.
Spare bangers.
Glass.
Plastic.
Clothing.
I should not have stepped on this.
That is.
All right.
Well, after we got done
filming that video,
Dan who's in the British army,
went on tour to Afghanistan.
And after about a month of being there
his fingers still hurt.
He had this weird lump over
the side of his knuckle,
that wouldn't heal.
So, we got an X Ray
and it turned out that
he did indeed have
a chunk of glass
lodged against his knuckle.
That is disgusting.
So, they took it out for him.
And now he's got a couple of
stitches in the side of his
finger.
So he's all fixed.
So, moral of the story is,
don't put a banger in a glass jar
and be less than a foot away
from it when it goes off.
Cause it's really dumb.
You get molded. All right.
I hope you enjoyed banger week.
Be sure to follow us both on
Twitter and check back again
soon. There'll be a new video.